corona hat ganze arbeit geleistet die
wirtschaft liegt am boden
noch nie seit dem zweiten weltkrieg war
das wachstum so niedrig die
frühjahrsprojektion der bundesregierung
ist wahrlich keine frohe botschaft
millionen menschen sind in kurzarbeit
pleiten und steigende arbeitslosigkeit
werden folgen
der staat unterstützt mit
hilfsprogrammen aber welche sind
wirklich sinnvoll und wäre jetzt die
gelegenheit um zu steuern für einen
wirtschaften nach corona im sinne von
klimaschutz und digitalisierung nach der
vollbremsung wie kommt die wirtschaft
wieder in gang unser thema heute in der
phoenix runde
[Musik]
der umstand dass vw und daimler
nach wochenlangem produktionsstillstand
ihre produktion seien anfang dieser
woche wieder hochfahren ist ein
deutliches und positives zeichen
aber es ändert nichts daran dass wir bei
dem ergebnis von minus 6,3 prozent
wachstum in diesem jahr die schwerste
rezession in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik deutschland erleben
werden
soweit also der
bundeswirtschaftsminister - 63 das ist
die harte zahl über die folgen sprechen
wir heute abend hier in der phoenix
runde mit diesen gästen in berlin ist an
bord gregor gysi mitglied des
bundestages für die linke zehn jahre
lang war er fraktionsvorsitzender seiner
partei und er ist präsident der
europäischen linken schönen guten abend
begrüßte stefan kooths er ist
konjunkturchef des instituts für
weltwirtschaft in kiel herzlich
willkommen und zugeschaltet sind uns
monika schnitzer sie ist professorin für
wirtschaftswissenschaften an der ludwig
maximilians universität in münchen
sie ist mitglied des
sachverständigenrates und wird kurz so
alt eben immer als wirtschaftsweise
benannt schönen guten abend frau
schnitzer und ich begrüße seiner größer
sie ist bundesvorsitzender des verbandes
die jungen unternehmer und designierte
nachfolgerin der zement ruhr und
betonwerke karl römer und sohn in
mundelsheim schönen guten abend
frauenhäuser das sind schlechte
nachrichten und harte zahlen die da
heute präsentiert wurden vom
bundeswirtschaftsminister wo merken sie
denn inzwischen die korona krise ganz
konkret in ihrem familienunternehmen ja
also ja ist man ihn umgeben sind ja in
der tv branche tätigen wir sind zum
glück nicht vom sturm betroffen
aber ich spreche in meiner funktion als
bundesvorsitzender von den jungen
unternehmer für den deutschen
mittelstand und familienunternehmen und
ich kann nicht sagen wir leben davon
einer historisch einmaligen situation
die alle
unternehmensgrößen und wirklich auch
alle branchen trifft hier vielleicht
einmal ein paar zahlen zu nennen zwei
drittel der familienunternehmen gleichen
seit beginn des shuttles und unter
umsatzausfällen 60 prozent an kurzarbeit
angemeldet und bei 30 prozent reicht die
liquidität keine sechs wochen mehr und
das ist natürlich sehr beunruhigend vor
allem wenn wir uns überlegen wenn dieses
eine dritte unternehmen wegfällt dann
hat das eine katastrophale
kettenreaktion zur folge und das sollten
wir tun nichts vermeiden was wäre denn
für sie das wichtigste was jetzt
passieren müsste damit um das zu
vermeiden
ja wir kommen vielleicht mit dem blauen
auge davon wenn wir jetzt schauen dass
wir sprachen dort wohnen beschließen
natürlich parallel die möglichkeit des
gesundheits gesundheitsschutz noch
besser ausschöpfen
also wir brauchen wirklich eine
perspektive wir brauchen eine
branchenübergreifende öffnung für die
wirtschaft damit wir als unternehmen
auch wieder selber erwirtschaften können
und die hilfsprogramme gar nicht
brauchen
herr gysi wenn sie das zuhören dann
sieht es eben schlecht aus für die
wirtschaft das heißt es sieht auch sehr
schlecht aus für viele arbeitnehmer die
wahrscheinlich ihren job verlieren
können oder länger in kurzarbeit bleiben
müssen
wie wichtig ist es dass der staat jetzt
die arbeitnehmer rettet also für die
pandemie ist der staat nicht
verantwortlich aber für alle
entscheidungen wir in diesem
zusammenhang getroffen hat ist er
verantwortlich
und wenn ich so etwas andere anordnet
damit natürlich die wirtschaft haben
läge die leute ein bisschen namen lege
kontakt verbote aussprechen dann müssen
zwei dinge ganz klar sein erstens darf
nur vorübergehender natur sein alles
muss wieder rückgängig gemacht werden
weil wir jetzt in den rat beschließen
selbst wenn wir finden das eine oder
andere hat sich bewährt dann müssen wir
noch mal demokratisch darüber
diskutieren dann kommt was neu
beschließen
und das zweite ist man wird sich
wirklich gedanken machen wie man den
leuten und der wirtschaft helfen kann
anders wird es nicht gehen
das nämlich drei punkte nennen wenn die
leute mehr verdient kaufen sie mehr
allen das stärkt auch die wirtschaft
zweitens die frauenberufe wissen sie
kann ich nicht leiden
und die sind so schlecht bezahlt dass
die männer deshalb nicht hingehen aber
das sage ich schon seit jahren
krankenschwester im verkäuferin und
pflegerinnen vor allen dingen das zweite
ist ein konjunkturprogramm
wir haben ein investitionsrückstand in
deutschland laut einschätzung des städte
und gemeindetages von 126 milliarden
euro das gilt für schulen das gilt für
straßen das gilt für brücken das gilt
für ganz viele bereiche und die
bundesregierung war so verliebt in die
schwarze null
dabei ist es so wenn sich heute gedenkt
ist hinfällig geworden
wenn man sich heute geld und kriegt man
sogar noch geld dazu das heißt wir
müssen investieren und das dritte ich
bin auch gar nicht dagegen einzelnen
unternehmen zu helfen wie adidas oder
damals im finanzkrise der commerzbank
nur unter der bedingung dass ich dann
auch ein anteil der gewinne kriege also
selbst juncker hat mir erzählt dass er
das in luxemburg immer so gemacht hat
wenn hat den banken geholfen hat bekam
man über einige jahre immer ein anteil
am gewinn
wir machen das alle blieben ohne nein
wenn die steuerzahlerinnen und
steuerzahler im unternehmen in der not
helfen dann muss es auch beteiligt seien
nicht überzogen aber beteiligt sein
zumindest für eine bestimmte frist an
gewinnen aber konjunkturprogramme sind
wirklich gerade für ihr unternehmen
diese ganzen bauunternehmen die brauchen
ja das für die infrastruktur entwickeln
ok also das wäre ihr wären ihre
vorschläge frau schnitzer wo machen was
noch mal konkreter beinahe bei dieser
schlimmsten rezession die jetzt uns
droht vovo merken wir einzelnen bürger
und jeder steuerzahler wo wird er das
merken wie teuer wird dass das hängt
ganz davon ab wie schnell die krise
jetzt tatsächlich überwunden wird und
das haben wir nicht alleine in der hand
das hängt einerseits davon ab wie
schnell die maßnahmen
gesundheitsmaßnahmen wirken wie schnell
wir die infektion wirklich eindämmen
und dann hängt es aber auch davon ab wie
schnell dass sie den anderen ländern
gelingt wir sind ja international
verflochten
wir verkaufen in andere länder 414
vorprodukte aus anderen ländern und nur
wenn es auf der ganzen welt aber
zumindest in europa auch in den anderen
ländern wieder aufwärts geht werden wir
zu normalen verhältnissen zurückkehren
das heißt aber darauf können wir uns
nicht verlassen was können wir denn
selber anstoßen
das hängt jetzt wiederum davon ab aus
welchen gründen die wirtschaftliche
aktivität zurzeit nicht funktioniert
also nehmen wir mal das
gaststättengewerbe oder das hotelwesen
und wenn man aktuell sei es doch nicht
aufmachen darf dann kann man natürlich
auch kein geld verdienen das wird sich
in dem moment ändern wo wir konzept zu
haben diese bereiche wieder zu öffnen
vermutliche noch eine gewisse zeit da
auch abstände eingehalten werden müssen
mit masken gearbeitet hatten müssen aber
ich habe schon die hoffnung dass man in
einem bestimmten bereich auch bald
wieder öffnen kann
das hotelgewerbe wird auf die
ausländischen gäste noch eine ganze
weile verzichten müssen vielleicht auch
auf gäste die man sonst die messe
bereich beispielsweise erlebt aber dafür
wird das inländische gäste geben ich
könnte mir vorstellen dass in diesem
jahr zumindest die deutschen im
tourismus ziele im inland wählen und das
wird dann auch der mit dem hotelgewerbe
nutzen wird wahrscheinlich nicht alles
ausgleichen aber wäre eine möglichkeit
herr codes was wo werden wir alle das
spüren was kostet das jeden von uns
diese rezession
ja ich möchte eben darauf eingehen dass
es alle bereiche trifft so ist es ja
nicht das trifft alle bereiche sehr
unterschiedlich und genau da müssen wir
jetzt ansetzen
da helfen auch keine konjunkturprogramme
ein hotelier hat nichts davon wenn sie
jetzt die bauwirtschaft anschieben zumal
die bauwirtschaft am allerwenigsten
unter der jetzigen krise leidet also von
diesem instrument würde ich warnen was
wir jetzt dringend brauchen als
ergänzung zu den liquiditätshilfen die
sehr schnell entschieden worden sind und
die auch richtig waren
wir brauchen jetzt einen
branchenübergreifenden lastenausgleich
denn jeder tag ohne normale umsätze
frisst sich in das eigenkapital der
unternehmen und kredite alleine reichen
dort auf dauer nicht
es werden ja beispielsweise
gastronomen viel härter getroffen mit
viel größeren verlusten als andere
unternehmen
sie tragen aber alle dazu bei dass das
gesundheitspolitische ziel erreicht
werden kann
also sollten auch die lasten
entsprechend verteilt werden und wir
brauchen jetzt das signal dass es nach
überstandener krise eine entsprechende
abrechnung gibt damit nicht die leute
individuell auf ihren verlusten sitzen
bleiben aber wir wissen ja gar nicht wie
lange die krise dauert also wie kann der
staat das jetzt zusagen für ein bereich
oder einen zeitraum gehen da gar nicht
einschätzen kann
ja er muss es ihnen eben offen lassen er
braucht einen allgemeinen mechanismus
und den muss er jetzt ankündigen damit
die unternehmen auch hoffnung schöpfen
dahingehend dass es sich lohnt
durchzuhalten pragmatischer vorschlag
wir nehmen die betriebs überschüsse des
vorjahres 2009 10
und zwar branche für branche nach dem
jeweiligen durchschnitten und sagen von
dem was davon jetzt auch ausfällt als
setzen wir einen bestimmten anteil sagen
wir mal 80 prozent oder 90 prozent
da nehmen wir einen großteil des
branchenbezogenen kreditrisikos heraus
und die banken wissen dann wenn ich
einem gastronom ein kredit gäbe dann
muss sich nur auf sein ganz
individuelles risiko schauen ist das ein
guter oder schlechter wird ja oder nein
aber das allgemeine systemische
branchen- risiko dass er der
gastronomiebranche angehört das nimmt
der staat heraus da muss er ein stück
weit ins ungewisse gehen das tut er aber
mit den garantien ohnehin es kommt jetzt
darauf an dass die auch sachgerecht
abgerufen werden können
es hilft nichts dass wir die großen
rettungsschirme aufgespannt haben und
die unternehmen nehmen sie nicht in
anspruch weil ich sagen es geht am ende
alles auf unser eigenes eigenkapital
das müssen wir jetzt sehr schnell
angehen also das risiko sollte der staat
dann halt eben teil das muss erst heilen
derzeit ist ja stellvertretend für die
gesamte gesellschaft ev häuser wäre das
was was ihnen und ihr den
unternehmen ihres verbandes helfen würde
also grundsätzlich muss ich sagen die
politik hat wirklich schnell gehandelt
hat auch die hilfsmaßnahmen auf die
straße gebracht die uns sehr geholfen
haben
aber natürlich weiß nicht wo ich schon
erwähnt habe wir müssen gucken dass wir
schnellstmöglich alle branchen wie der
hotellerie gastronomie einzelhandel so
schnell wie möglich der in gang bringen
auch damit die finanziellen löcher nicht
zu groß werden wir als unternehmer oder
die unternehmer die jetzt gerade in
diesem mittelstand zurückgefallen das
heißt kredite aufnehmen müssen
das würden wir gerne verhindern und das
spreche für diese branchen denn wir
würden lieber gerne eine eine öffnung
erst möglich eröffnung hinbekommen dass
wir diese kredite gar nicht erst in
anspruch nehmen wird ist derzeit für
sich aus eine ist auch umsetzbar
das heißt sie würden dann aber lieber
sie würden wären auch bereit ein höheres
risiko medizinisch einst von ihm
gesundheitlich für die bevölkerung dass
sie sagen okay und wer ist das so
wichtig und das wachstum das wir sagen
wir müssen das ist das allerwichtigste
dass wir lockern oder verstehe ich sie
da falsch die gesundheit steht immer an
erster stelle und man hat ja auch
gesehen weil die unternehmen die
weiterhin geöffnet hat während des
schattens das ist möglich ist die
hygiene und abstandsregeln einzuhalten
mit einer entsprechenden schutzkleidung
mit dem test die ausgeweitet werden
müssen
es ist ja möglich system ad racing at
wenn wir alle diese schutzmaßnahmen auch
einführen
dann können wir auch die wirtschaft
wieder hochfahren 94 prozent der
unternehmen wären auch bereit mit ihren
mitarbeitern mit merck dann auch sofort
startklar
da muss man wirtschaft und gesundheit in
einklang bringen und ja gesundheit ist
oberste priorität ganz klar aber wir
können es schaffen
herr gysi ist dass die abwägung die man
kann man die so treffen also die es gibt
auch einige wirtschaftsverbände haben
wir dann den kanzleramtsminister
brauchen jetzt auch ein brandbrief
geschrieben haben gesagt vor dem treffen
dass er morgen stattfinden soll zwischen
der ministerpräsident und der kanzlerin
das ist ganz wichtig ist das
wiederanfahren der wirtschaft ist eine
perspektive braucht wie viel druck kann
man da eigentlich ist es ja eigentlich
richtig da haben sie auch recht aber
sind nicht in der rolle der politiker
wissen sie der eine virologe sagt mir
dass alles übertrieben und gar nicht
der andere sagt wenn sie das nicht
machen kriegen sie eine million
impliziert und über 100.000 tote ja wer
will denn dafür die verantwortung
übernehmen da wir alle keine virologen
sind kannst du dir dann immer aussuchen
nach welcher meinung du dich richtig ist
und dann nimmt die politik natürlich
immer die die größte gefahr beschreiben
weil sie eben nicht die verantwortung
für millionen infizierte und tote haben
wollen das verstehe ich sie hat 2012
fehler gemacht weil sie da eigene
experten beauftragt hat die haben gesagt
wir brauchen schutzanzüge masten also
alles nicht gekauft aber darüber will
ich jetzt gar nicht reden übrigens hat
er recht was ich gesagt habe zum
konjunkturprogramm das bezieht sich auf
unsere gesamte entwicklung und unseren
rückstand in der infrastruktur bei
straßen brücken schulen und in vielen
anderen bereichen lastenausgleich ist
nicht schlecht ist sowieso ein schönes
wort es ist indirekt war das auch eine
art vermögenssteuer aber völlig kann das
aber nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
heute sehe er ein anders aus der
lastenausgleich hätte ich auch nichts
dagegen aber es gibt zwei punkte auf die
ich hinweisen muss die bundesregierung
hat zum beispiel zurecht 9000 euro zur
verfügung gestellt
auch für solo selbständige freiberufler
und freiberufler sie sagt aber nur für
betriebskosten
das gibt es wieder nicht bei den solo
selbstständigen und den freiberufler
haben wir nur eine wohnung wo sie
arbeiten wenn sie aber davon die miete
nicht bezahlen ich habe sie gebeten an
drei minister habe ich schon geschrieben
streicht das uns sagt sie können das
ausgehen anders geht das meines
erachtens nicht
das zweite ist dass tatsächlich die
gaststätten und hotels mit in der
schwierigsten situation sind wobei man
nicht vergessen darf in deutschland und
immer alles von der miete bezahlt die
unteren künstler nicht und bei den
großen konzernen banken und den reichen
traut man sich nicht heran dadurch
bezahlt alles die mitte der mittelstand
die mittleren einkommen und das darf so
nicht bleiben bisschen was mich ärgert
bei den gaststätten und hotels die
versicherung es gibt ja viele die haben
eine ausfallversicherung und die zahlen
nicht ich bin jetzt juristisch begründen
wie sie das machen aber das geht nicht
dass sie ein bezahlen und die anderen
bezahlen nichts insofern essen was
ausgleich aber stehen sie herrn
berechtigt und wir müssen tatsächlich
uns bei den hotels und restaurants bars
eine wende wenn wir jetzt geschichte mit
800 quadratmetern eröffnet
90 900 quadratmeter warum nicht frei
also ich will muss ja alles eine logik
würde ich gerne darauf eingehen was wir
jetzt vermeiden müssten sind lauter
kleinteilige eingriffe aber auch lauter
branchenspezifische rettungsprogramme
das wäre keine gute idee zu sagen jetzt
lassen wir uns etwas für die hoteliers
einfallen lassen wir uns etwas andere
für die automobilindustrie einfallen am
ende haben wir den abwrackprämien hier
wir haben mehrwertsteuersenkungen dort
und der dritte bekommt sein kollegium
platz der konzerte soldaten bei seinen
konsum gutschein
das ist nicht sachgerecht und macht die
sache am ende teurer als ist sein muss
der allgemeine mechanismus ein
lastenausgleichs nimmt ja genau zur
kenntnis dass die verschiedenen branchen
unterschiedlich stark betroffen sind das
heißt die bauwirtschaft würde relativ
wenig ersetzt bekommt weil dort die
ausfälle relativ gering sind die
hoteliers die gastwirte würden sehr viel
ersetzt bekommt aufwand aber allgemein
als es an allgemeine regel die wir
vorschlagen eine regel geben und eine
das ist ja ohnehin fast ein treppenwitz
zu sagen ihr dürfen keine umsätze machen
aber dafür senken wir euch die
umsatzsteuer das ist nicht wirksam das
ist eigentlich etwas und das muster
kommt jetzt immer wieder
jetzt kommen lauter vorschläge jetzt auf
den tisch die man vor corinna nicht hat
durchsetzen können aber meint jetzt mit
dem rückenwind der krise
und weil die öffentlichen kassen gerade
weit offen sind könnte jeder mal
eingreifen sollten wir nicht ich habe
mir daher sicher was das stichwort
lassen ausland gerne aufgreifen
präsidenten der schnelle sagen welche
welche hilfen hilfe sinnvoll erhalten
also zum stichwort lastenausgleich ich
glaube ich es aktuell noch schwer
wirklich zu sagen wir am schluss am
meisten betroffen sein wird ich habe
frauen angesprochen es gibt eben auch
die branchen die von dem export schwer
belastet sind weil die zulieferer
produkte fehlen und so weiter und mir
wäre es wichtig beim thema
lastenausgleich tatsächlich darauf zu
achten wer anschluss für die schulden
aufkommen muss die wir jetzt aufnehmen
werden
und da wäre das thema
generationengerechtigkeit für mich ganz
wichtig ist wir können das gleich noch
vertiefen
mir wäre es deswegen auch wichtig jetzt
nicht so ganz allgemein
zu sagen wir müssen alle ein bisschen
helfen und es daran festmachen die ging
es den kassen vor der krise oder den
einzelunternehmen vor der krise denn
durch die krise wird sich auch
strukturell einiges ändern und manche
werden gar nie wieder so groß werden
vielleicht wird der tourismus nach der
krise anders aussehen vielleicht werden
wir nach der krise weniger autofahren es
wird alles mögliche sich ändern
und deswegen müssen wir wenn wir jetzt
an denken die wirtschaft wieder langsam
hochzufahren überlegen wo wir die
strukturellen schwerpunkte setzen wollen
wie wird das programm dann nutzen können
um die notwendigen strukturellen
veränderungen zu befördern statt die
existierenden strukturen zementiert
jedes andere bedingung sei ganz
kurzfristig nur noch mal zum nachfragen
und daher kurz das heißt sie sehen da
auch eine chance das heißt dass wir
können auch besser vielleicht aus dieser
krise herauskommen verstärkt wir können
auf jeden fall mit dem was wir jetzt
reinstecken insbesondere wenn wir an so
was wie konjunkturprogramme denken
können wir wirklich akzente setzen und
wir dürfen an der stelle nicht da
hingehen und sagen wir wollen alles so
haben wie es vorher war
weil das war ja schon vorher nicht alles
genauso wie sein sollte wir wohl hatten
schon vorher zum beispiel das
klimaproblem wir werden jetzt dieses
konjunkturpaket wenn es wenn dann kommt
nutzen müssen um genau diese akzente zu
setzen klimafreundliche bereiche zu
fördern klimafreundlichen energien zu
fördern
in die digitalisierung zu gehen also all
die bereiche zu fördern und zu
finanzieren indem wir im rückstand haben
frauen sehr schnell wie ich dann ganz
wer hingegen sie okay müssen investieren
aber wir müssen richtig in das ok frau
größer weil frau schnitzer die
generationengerechtigkeit angesprochen
hat und sie als junge unternehmen
natürlich genau darauf schauen auf die
frage wer muss für die schulden dann
aufkommen was sind ihre befürchtungen
dafür ihre generation die mittel
es ist natürlich ein großes
thema und es treibt nicht auf und viele
in meiner generation auch uns bei uns an
bei den jungen unternehmen
wir wissen dass wir diese schulden und
berge die jetzt anhäufen ja auch später
bezahlen müssen
und das gegen bled hier ich auch dafür
auf das erwirtschaften und das ist ein
wichtiger punkt ist dass die wirtschaft
wieder anfährt
weil hier natürlich als junge generation
die korona schermer auch wieder
einsammeln müssen wir müssen schauen
dass wegen der unternehmen hat die
familienunternehmen wieder auf die
straße fliegen dass wir erfolgreich sind
arbeitsplätze nach wie vor sichern
können erhalten können und es wird
natürlich eine sehr große
herausforderung für uns werden und
deswegen ist es auch wichtig nach kona
wieder zur sozialen marktwirtschaft
zurückzukehren ist eine soziale
marktwirtschaft post und uns auch wieder
auf die prinzipien zurück besinnen und
jetzt auch genau gedanken machen für was
wir steuergelder ausgeben
aber sie sind ja ein bisschen in den
bremer zum einen brauchen sie das
anfahren der wirtschaft auf der erde die
staatliche unterstützung auf der anderen
seite wollen sie nicht dass er so viel
schulden aufgenommen werden wo sehen sie
denn da den den besten weg für sich also
wie ich vorhin schon erwähnt habe es war
wichtig und richtig dass dieses rakete
schnell kamen aber jetzt in einem in
einem immer wie sie richtig sagen dass
wir schnell wieder ins erwirtschaften
kommt es dass die finanziellen
wahrscheinlich noch größer werden weil
es werden sie wenn ihr jetzt nicht
branchenweite öffnen werden kurzfristig
wir wollten noch gerne was so vor
schnitt verfahren ja also wir müssen
aufpassen dass aus den hilfsmilliarden
jetzt kein spielgeld für eine neue
industriepolitik wird es mag sein dass
die strukturen ändern
das wissen die aber derzeit noch nicht
genau welche struktur und sich wie
ändern und deshalb müssen wir auch dass
den unternehmen überlassen wenn wir ihn
jetzt einen teil ihrer gewinn ausfälle
ersetzen können sie ja selber
entscheiden wie sie weiter disponieren
ob sie sich beispielsweise damit im
bereich digitalisierung stärken oder
etwas anderes tun das sollte jetzt nicht
der staat auch noch vorgehen dafür haben
wir gar keine zeit und wir haben auch
gar nicht das wissen dass wir jetzt
schon wüssten
idealen wirtschaftsstrukturen ausdruck
dass wir bei der digitalisierung hinten
dran sind wir wissen dass wir beim
klimaschutz viele ziele nicht erreichen
da könnte man doch jetzt nutzen um zu
sagen genau das fördern wir ja das
können wir aber nicht übers knie brechen
über ein konjunkturprogramm also wir
sollten jetzt auch nicht alles in frage
stellen was vor der krise richtig und
wichtig und stabil wie hat die funktions
liege wir hatten weiter mitteilen
funktionsfähige wirtschaftsstrukturen
die sind durch den virus unterbrochen
worden es ist erstmal die diagnose und
alles was man sich jetzt auf der langen
frist vorstellt beispielsweise in der
klimapolitik kann man jetzt nicht binnen
ein oder zwei jahren umsetzen man sollte
ja davor ein man sollte sagen dass erst
vor der korona krise richtig war ist
auch nach der korona krise richtig man
sollte jetzt also hier praktisch nicht
einfach hektisch um steuern aber das was
vor der korona krise falsch war wird
auch nicht automatisch durch corona
richtig das heißen wir müssen jetzt
klimapolitik umso effizienter machen bei
uns einfach die finanziellen mittel auch
knapper werden sie haben die
auslaufenden schulden abgetragen werden
müssen ja erwähnt das heißt wir sollten
jetzt auch hier raus aus allen
kleinteiligen interventionistischen
programmen und viel stärker auf
preismechanismen setzen damit der
klimaschutz billiger wird okay müssen
diese antwort jetzt gehen die sie was
ist ihre meinung
damit können wir in richtung
digitalisierung klimaschutz jetzt dinge
steuern ja erstens müssen wir das wir
haben doch gar keine andere chance wenn
der klimawandel so weitergeht wird das
die junge generation hart treffen würde
ich bin 72 bis zu meinem lebensende
halte ich den klimawandel noch aus aber
die jungen leute doch nicht die haben
jahrzehnte leben vor sich und da können
wir nicht einfach danebenstehen und
sagen die unternehmen wir lassen das man
alles so laufen das geht nicht ich
glaube es gibt zwei möglichkeiten ich
hoffe unsere wirtschaftsweise hat recht
und wir verbessern die dinge nach der
krise es kann natürlich auch das
gegenteil passieren der egoismus nimmt
zu der nationale egoismus der
individuelle egoismus ist eine
katastrophe der abbau der demokratie
bleibt partiell bestehen das wäre eine
katastrophe
gegen all das müssen wir uns wenden aber
ich sage auch wir müssen ein paar
grundlinie
finde es gute idee das kurzarbeitergeld
auf 80 und 87 prozent zu erhöhen dass
wir einen augenblick ganz wichtig ich
habe schon von den 9000 euro gesprochen
aber was mir auch wichtig ist ist bei
der wirtschaft die ökonomie ökologie und
die soziale frage endlich in
übereinstimmung zu bringen
ökologische nachhaltigkeit ist wichtig
aber in sozialer verantwortung kann ich
einpacken revier schließen und sagen was
aus den kumpeln wird interessiert mich
nicht das geht einfach nicht das tut ja
vielleicht nein aber vielleicht fangen
wir ja wirklich an umzudenken
wissen sie was mich in deutschland seit
jahren stört wirklich noch mal dass
alles von der mittel bezahlt wird warum
die großen nicht bezahlen müssen konkret
kontrollieren wer sollte bezahlen müssen
banken die großen konzerne die riesige
gewinne machen und wenn wir ihnen helfen
werden wir eben nicht mal an den
gewinnen beteiligt das schießen und
überhaupt nicht ein
und zweitens müssen die endlich mal
gerecht steuern bezahlen der mittelstand
muss immer gerecht steuern bezahlen
immer in deutschland und die großen
konzerne den werden immer wege gezeigt
wie sowas von meyer heißt dass sie wegen
der meister die automobilindustrie jetzt
konkret zu unterstützen ich habe nichts
dagegen wir können die
automobilindustrie unterstützen und dann
will ich an den gewinnen
eine weile lang beteiligt sein also wenn
die steuerzahlerinnen und steuerzahler
ihr geld dorthin geben müssen sie auch
was davon haben und zwar nicht nur das
gericht räumt ich sage mal das beispiel
mit der commerzbank nicht die hat
wirklich viel geld gekriegt und dann
reden wir den steuern hinterher dann
fehlen ihnen noch tricksen die der
mittelstand nie hat der muss immer eher
steuern belasten wie sich das warten wir
den euro sie nerven zerren oder gewinne
frau schnitzer was machen wir es noch
mal konkret zum beispiel bei der
automobil industrie die ja jetzt ganz
die unterstützung haben möchte es sollte
eigentlich ein treffen oder eine
video-konferenz mit das ja heute alles
immer so ist von den ministerpräsidenten
kretschmann weil und söder heute geben
das ist jetzt erstmal verschoben aber es
ist klar dass das nächste woche soll
darüber auch natürlich im kanzleramt
gesprochen werden welche hilfen bräuchte
die automobilindustrie konkret also
tatsächlich ist es natürlich so dass die
ina automobilbranche momentan enorme
umsatzeinbußen erlebt weil eben der
absatz martina beck welt auch alle
starten
aber es wird vermutlich auch nicht
wieder so werden wie es vorher war
und da gibt es eben struktur und brüche
die sich schon abgezeichnet haben die
deutsche automobilbranche hat ja schon
vor der krise schwierigkeiten am
horizont gesehen weil sie nach wie vor
auf den verbrennungsmotor gesetzt hat
und es wäre jetzt völlig verkehrt in dem
man jetzt die klima auflage reduziert
wie gefordert wird von der
automobilbranche oder indem man
abwrackprämien ihnen zugeschickt für
verbrennungs in diesem motor autos diese
struktur zu zementieren was wir wirklich
brauchen ist jetzt eine förderung der
erneuerbaren energien der elektromotor
ist sehr autos die mit ein stoff zellen
fahren mit entsprechender infrastruktur
so dass das ganze funktioniert damit wir
als land auch ein neues
wettbewerbsmodell haben wir müssen ihn
die wettbewerbsfähigkeit der zukunft
investieren die alten motoren werden uns
die gewinne in den nächsten jahrzehnten
nicht erwirtschaften das ist ein
irrglaube
hierdurch zeichnet die strukturellen
umbrüche ab und wir müssen jetzt
voranschreiten um in zukunft marktführer
in diesen technologien zu sein und an
der stelle will ich nicht insofern eher
kurze ich will nicht dass der staat sagt
die oder die technologie sollte nutzen
das sollte tatsächlich technologieoffen
seien aber die die erneuerbaren energien
an sich müssen gefördert werden wir
dürfen nicht auf die alten systeme
setzen und antrag prämien ausgeben so
wie wir das bei der letzten finanzkrise
gemacht haben was tatsächlich völlig
ineffizient die leute haben das damals
genutzt um ausländische autos zu kaufen
das hat der eigenen branche ganz wenig
gebracht es war ein unglaublich tolles
programm und am ende ohne große
verbreiten viele wissenschaftliche
studien auch ausbaden übrigens aber auch
für deutschland das war völlig in der
vollkommen beieinander dass es nach
gerade obszön steuergeld dafür
auszugeben dass güter vernichtet werden
das ist ja die idee einer abwrackprämie
wir haben einen wir wir produzieren um
am ende konsumgüter damit zu erlangen
und eine abwrackprämie macht die
produktion zum selbstzweck das führt den
gesamten wirtschaftsprozess ad absurdum
war vielleicht lernen wir jetzt sagt
wirtschaft doch für die menschen da sein
muss und nicht nur für ein profil
wussten ja ökonomischen
befürchten sie dass sozusagen durch
diese krise jetzt noch mal andere
mechanismen in gang kommen und dass man
zum beispiel energie noch mal höher
besteuert das ist ja eine klage von
vielen unternehmen dass die
energiepreise itzehoer zu teuer sind
also haben sie angst dass das es in der
richtung geht die ihnen dann wieder für
ihr unternehmen und für ihre unternehmen
das noch mal schwieriger machen würde im
sinne der zum beispiel der decke des
klimaschutzes
ja also wir brauchen natürlich ja einen
neuen staat auf den klimaschutz aus
meiner sicht ist es im prinzip ganz so
schlecht schwer
ich würde dass er vorschlagen den
europäischen emissionshandel einfach
auszuweiten da besteht die möglichkeit
alle sektoren der grundversorgung nicht
enthalten die verkehr landwirtschaft mit
einzugliedern
damit wäre es auch möglich dass
ökologische ziele im klimaschutz zu
erreichen und sicher zu stellen ich
glaube da haben wir ein gutes instrument
das wir auch einsetzen sollten also sie
befürchten nicht das ist jetzt das ist
dass durch diese krise dass es noch eine
allen maßnahmen verschärft werden
ja also ich mal wissen tue ich nicht
aber ich denke wir haben gute
instrumente und maßnahmen die wir
einleiten können und es ist auf jeden
fall die möglichkeit genau solche dinge
nie den europäischen emissionshandel
auszuweiten und anzustoßen und es
endlich mein angriff zu nehmen wenn er
tatsächlich keine damals sei es dass an
der stelle ergänzen tatsächlich könnte
man eben die energie preise senken
arbeit zwar für für elektrizität hier
haben wir genau die preise zu hoch sind
wir haben eine zu hohe steuern wir
sollten die steuerjahre unternehmen und
durch den staatshaushalt wenn dann sehen
wir sollten die eeg umlage durch den
staatshaushalt finanzieren das würde die
bürger entlasten das würde die industrie
das gewerbe entlasten und würde dann
anreize setzen zum beispiel in
wärmepumpen zu investieren also eben in
aldi
instrumente zu investieren für die man
dann elektrizität verwenden kann die mit
erneuerbarer energie hergestellt worden
ist
das würde genau den klimawandel fordern
und gleichzeitig die bürgerinnen und
bürger und die industrie entlassen da
die professorin völlig recht das problem
besteht doch darin dass ökologische
produkte erst mal teurer sind als nicht
ökologische produkte
das müssen wir doch mal begreifen dass
man das drehen muss bei der
energieversorgung genauso wie in anderen
bereichen ja aber das sind alles dinge
die waren auch vor der korona krise
schon werden jetzt nein das ist man es
unterstützt das vollkommen was hier
gesagt worden ist wir müssen über die
mich an die technologische das macht
sondern auch die ökologischen ziele zu
erreichen das war aber auch schon vor
der krise richtig
das ist jetzt aber kein instrument wie
wir die unternehmen übernächsten sage
ich mal drei vier fünf sechs quartale
bringen das ist jetzt die akute
problematik die sich stellt und auch die
müssen wir eine antwort geben
den können wir jetzt nicht damit kommen
dass wir sagen wir werden eine änderung
in der in der energie- preisregulierung
vornehmen das hilft den unternehmen
jetzt konkret nicht da können sie ja
noch mal eine eigene runde darüber
machen verfahren eine menge zu sagen
aber heute geht es darum wie wir
überhaupt wieder zurückkommen auf
ehemalige produktionsniveaus oder in die
nähe von ehemaligen produktion und der
hilfestellung zur debatte so interessant
sie sein mag sie hilft uns hier nicht im
moment brauchen wir die staatliche
unterstützung das ist klar die
wirtschaft schafft das nicht alleine
herr gysi sie haben ja lange gesagt die
schwarze null halten sie nicht für
sinnvoll aber ist war sie nicht doch
sehr sinnvoll denn wegen der schwarzen
null können wir uns jetzt all diese
leute hilfe leisten sehen sie das
inzwischen anders
so sehe ich mich anders weil die these
wird dann immer aufgestellt weil man
etwas durchbricht das ist aber sehr
sinnvoll war es bis dahin so zu machen
das problem ist dass wir seit jahren
eine so niedrige zinspolitik haben dass
die aufnahme von darlehen durch die
regierung sogar dazu führte sie noch
geld dazu bekommen das gab es nun nach
45 glaube ich noch nie
das ist eine völlig neue situation und
das hätte man nutzen müssen um in dieser
zeit den investitions rückstand
auszugleichen
wir haben bei straßen wir haben bei
brücken wir haben bei schulen wir haben
in vielen bereichen einen solchen
rückstand der städte gemeinsam klar geld
gibt momente voller krise als
sichtschutz
er stimmt gar nicht der städte und
gemeindetag hat den
investitionsrückstand auf 126 milliarden
euro geschätzt dass das wirklich
erheblich und wenn ich noch eine kleine
geschichte erzählen darf ich bin ja viel
durchs land gefahren worden und auch
gefahren und mein handy war ständig
unterbrochen und dann habe ich jemanden
getroffen der war in uganda und erzählte
mir dass sein handy dort nie
unterbrochen war so wollte ich der
bundesregierung vorstellen dass wir
entwicklungshilfe in uganda beantragen
ich meine es muss doch möglich sein
investitionen zu machen dass also die
moderne sage ich mal technologie dass
sie überall anwendbar ist in deutschland
das ist dass eine band oder dass die
zweite phase
das ist ja und das zweite ist dass im
augenblick die schulden ja sage ich noch
einmal geld bringen natürlich muss das
immer die nächste generation irgendwie
tragen aber das geht nur wenn wir in die
zukunft investieren wenn die nächste
generation wirklich etwas davon hat dann
ist das vertretbar wenn wir natürlich
schulden machen um irgendwas zu bezahlen
was mit der zukunft nichts zu tun hat
dann wäre das völlig daneben es geht um
die richtung der investition frau häuser
sind ziehen da ist ja die schwarze null
sind sie dankbar das ist und würden sie
dann daran auch weiter festhalten obwohl
sie jetzt merken dass man eben jetzt
eben gerade schulden machen muss absolut
also ich bin dankbar dass sie die
schwarze null haben und die
schuldenbremse wald hat es wirklich nur
möglich gemacht auch diese ausgaben
jetzt betätigen und ich hoffe wirklich
dass auch ein learning aus der korona
diese für uns alle ist etwas erhellendes
nämlich dass der wohlstand unserem land
nicht gottgegeben ist und die schwarze
null und die schuldenbremse da müssen
wir auch wieder zurück sie hatten es
jetzt geholfen und war auch gut dass wir
sie vorher hatten und da müssen doch
zurück wieder frau schnitt sahen ich
werde zu dem thema
infrastrukturmaßnahmen gerne noch mal
eingehen vorher ganz kurz zu herrn kurz
offensichtlich haben wir da gewisse
missverständnisse main
punkt war hier darüber zu reden wie
bringen wir die wirtschaft später wieder
ins laufen wenn wir durch die krise so
allmählich durch sind ihr punkt scheint
er zu sein wie halten wir sie momentan
überhaupt noch über wasser
das sind zwei verschiedene punkte
vielleicht erklärt sich das auch erklärt
dass auch wir da manchmal
unterschiedlicher meinung sind letzte
den infrastrukturmaßnahmen ein problem
das der feststellung ist es hat eben
nicht nur am geld gefehlt dass zu wenig
investiert wurde man zu sehr vielleicht
an der chance nur festgehalten hat es
hat eben auch an kapazität im baugewerbe
gefehlt und an planungs kapazität
innenbehörden beides ist abgebaut worden
und warum die behörden haben abgebaut
weil sie nichts mehr zu bauen hatte es
gab kein geld dafür ja aber es wurde
eben auch zu unregelmäßig gebaut und er
wird massiv eingespart und die behörden
haben jetzt also die idee die wand
deutschen behörden haben jetzt gar nicht
das personal um so schnell neue
programme aufzusetzen und gleichzeitig
ja die bei kapazität abgenommen weil zu
wenig aufträge über die letzten jahre
waren die ist sehr gut ausgestattet aber
sie hat insgesamt abgenommen ich finde
dass wir jetzt wirklich brauchen ist
eine planungssicherheit das heißt all
das was wir jetzt investieren sollten
und wir sollten investieren ja
insbesondere digitale ausbau und
bestimmte infrastrukturmaßnahmen das
muss mit einer planungssicherheit was
ihr nicht jetzt auf einmal alles sondern
eben zu sagen die nächsten zehn jahre so
und so viele regeln wann würde man so
dass die volle kapazität sich anpasst
und die planungskapazitäten den behörden
noch angepasst haben das würde jetzt
auch sozusagen den schlechten
wachstumszahlen dann schnell helfen das
würde doch dauernd in ein tatsächlich
hilft es doch erstaunlich gut also in
der letzten krise hat man ja auch soll
die baumaßnahmen finanziert und kollegen
von mir haben untersucht wie hat sich
das ausgewirkt
man hat festgestellt damals
beispielsweise hat mit geld ausgegeben
um energetische sanierungen in schulen
durchzuführen
man hat festgestellt nach einem
dreiviertel jahr nach nach der
ausgrabung der mittel waren die
arbeitsplätze da das heißt das hat
erstaunlich schnell funktioniert ganz
entgegen aller unkenrufe und es hat
gewirkt für 25.000 euro pro jahr gab es
einen
arbeitsplatz mehr und das hat einige
zeit lang angehalten
also das heißt man hat damals
festgestellt so was funktioniert ohne
solide unterstützen genau wird noch mal
gern darauf schauen wer ist eigentlich
alles bezahlen soll und ob wir da auch
andere ideen entwickeln könnten es gibt
die idee natürlich von der
vermögenssteuer vermögensabgabe es gibt
die idee dass die unternehmen die hohe
boni und dividenden zahlen dass sie das
dass sie dann keine hilfen bekommen er
kurz wo würden sie sagen wer könnte was
abgeben für diese krise also wir haben
ja im einkommensteuerrecht als
leistungsfähigkeit prinzip verankert und
genau daran sollte man festhalten
das heißt wir brauchen jetzt einen
tilgungsplan sobald die krise
überstanden ist
dann schauen wir uns die gestiegene
staatsverschuldung an die wir ganz
erheblich angeschwollen sein
über die nächsten ein zwei jahre und
dann muss dieser berg wieder getilgt
werden dass mussten nicht binnen zwei
jahren geschehen aber mindestens so wie
es die schuldenbremse auch vorsieht in
den nächsten 20 jahren anteilig
zurückgeführt werden das kann man machen
dafür braucht man keine vermögensabgabe
das würde die sache nur unnötig
verkomplizieren die ganze bewertung
nein das würde die sache nur unnötig
verkomplizieren im zweifel müssten
dennoch vermögensgüter verkauft werden
dann kriegen sie noch entsprechende
preiseffekte das kann man alles verdauen
über die ganz normale
einkommensbesteuerung und man muss
natürlich ändern ja man muss auch
darüber nachdenken nein muss man nicht
unbedingt man kann auch darüber
nachdenken auf der ausgabenseite zu
konsolidieren
wir sind in die krise hineingegangen mit
der größten staatseinnahmen quote die
wir im vereinigten deutschland jemals
hatten
also es nicht so dass wir immer nur nach
mehr einnahmen der sparte schauen
sollten das sollten auch mal schauen wo
können wir vielleicht etwas mai den
gürtel enger schnallen ok und das aber
die steuerzahler entlasten nein am ende
des tages das ist doch ganz klar die
steuerzahler müssten die schuld bezahlen
die steuerzahler ja man könnte ja das
können wir daran reizt dann ja aber
konsumanreize wenn sie wir reden jetzt
ja über die die tilgung der
aufgelaufenen schulden in den nächsten
ein bis zwei jahren
wie kommen wir von diesen schulden
buckel wieder runter und wir müssen vor
dem schulden buckel wieder runter denn
wir sehen ja jetzt gerade die
vergleichsweise soliden staatsfinanzen
deutschland erlauben uns eine sehr
großzügige große geophysikalische
reaktion
die krise ist sozusagen einzigartig aber
es wird mit sicherheit nicht die letzte
makro ökonomische krise sein und wir
müssen uns vorbereiten damit wir wieder
mit stabilen staatsfinanzen eben die
möglicherweise nächste krise hinein
energie sie wer soll dann mehr bezahlen
ja wir sind wir leute denen das gut geht
dir sagen immer den leuten sind es nicht
so gut geht wie sollen den gürtel enger
schnallen also den spruch kenne ich nun
schon seit vielen jahrzehnten
nein ich finde wir müssen anders heran
denken wir brauchen wirklich mehr
gerechtigkeit ich sage es noch einmal
die miete bezahlt in deutschland alles
das kann so nicht bleiben
das heißt wir müssen die oberen sowohl
im verdienst als auch im vermögen aber
vor allen dingen auch die großen
konzerne und banken anders als ein
mittelsmann bei ihrer also das kann ich
ihnen sagen ich würde den
spitzensteuersatz auf 53 prozent erhöhen
der galt unter helmut kohl und das war
kein linksextremist mehr würde ich nicht
nehmen aber nur für das was man mehr als
100000 euro im jahr verdient ich gehöre
dazu wir gehen daran nicht zugrunde dann
kann ich die mitte wieder entlastende im
einkommen bei den steuern ist es so ich
könnte den mittelstand nicht versprechen
wenn ich das zu entscheiden hätte dass
ich ein besser stelle aber eins könnte
ich versprechen dass ich ihn nicht
zusätzlich belastet sondern mehr
ernsthaft gedanken mache in ganz europa
über die großen banken und konzerne
gerecht heranziehen mich hat einen
mittelständler angerufen hat mir
folgendes erzählt ein konzern hat den
gewinn ickx und muss 100 millionen euro
darauf steuern bezahlen sagte sie wenn
ich den gewinnen gehabt hätte müsste ich
1,1 milliarden euro steuern darauf
bezahlen können sie mal das erklärt
diese ungerechtigkeit muss und noch
etwas es gibt in den usa ist hält sich
us-recht vorschlag bei einem punkt mache
ich das die binden die steuerpflicht
auch an die staatsbürgerschaft die sagen
als zu es bürgern und s-bahn kannst du
hinziehen wo du willst einmal im jahr
muss du vollständig sein einkommen was
du in der welt heißt angeben wie
versteuernde auf den seychellen oder wo
auch immer du zu bezahlen hass und wenn
du mehr in den usa zu bezahlen hast
musst du die differenz bezahlen
ich kenne leute die um monaco wohnt ich
könnte ihnen ja den blick aufs
mittelmeer
wenn sie solche sind sollten sie bei mir
steuerpflicht nicht bleibt
wer nicht mehr gerechtigkeit herstellen
werden wir eine unzufriedene mitte
bekommen die unteren sowieso aber auch
mitte das können wir uns gar nicht
leisten ja frau rosa was befürchten sie
wo würden sie hätten sie gerne mehr
gerechtigkeit für unternehmer und wenn
sie jetzt ja überlegen dass dieser stadt
dauert noch länger andauert also wie
lange halten ihre unternehmen das noch
aus nicht mehr lange also das bereitet
mir wie vor schon erwähnt wirklich
sorgen und das gegen nach wie vor wir
brauchen eine schnelle öffnung unter
einhaltung der gesundheitsschutz
maßnahmen und eine vermögenssteuer ist
nicht der richtige weg sondern wir
brauchen jetzt eine gesamten strecke und
nicht die alten klassenkampf forderungen
das ist aus meiner sicht nicht das
richtige
wer müsste sich denn mehr anstrengen
ihrer meinung nach also grundsätzlich
sind wir als wirtschaft mit unseren
mitarbeitern zusammen mit diejenigen die
auch die steuern zahlen und
erwirtschaften und von daher würde ich
mir wünschen dass es auch in zukunft
weiterhin so bleibt und deswegen müssen
wir schnell zurück um auch diese steuer
zahlen zu können und die den haushalt
wieder mit gelder zu füllen
das wirkt aber so als würden sie
eigentlich sagen müssen wir weitermachen
wie vorher muss jetzt nicht
grundsätzlich richtig viel ändern also
grundsätzlich haben wir ja gesehen jetzt
auch und das in diesem koffer legen wir
uns wirklich angespart haben
steuergelder uns geht es ja in
deutschland wirklich gut dass wir auch
diese krise jetzt so überstehen können
dass der so gutes gesundheitssystem
haben und ich bin der meinung das
wichtigste ist jetzt schnell wieder
zurück selber erwirtschaften wir als
unternehmen mit unseren mitarbeitern die
steuern zu zahlen damit wir auch wieder
auf den wohlstand zurückkommen weil der
ist natürlich jetzt geschwächt durch die
ganzen ausgaben in milliardenhöhe haben
das befürchten sie wenn es jetzt eben
nicht schnell
perspektive gibt dass wir dann eine
insolvenzwelle bekommen das heißt
unternehmen die grundsätzlich marktfähig
wehren müssen dann ausscheiden aus
liquiditätsgründen oder auch weil die
eigenkapitaldecke abgeschmolzen ist und
dann dauert eben auch die erholungsphase
wieder umso länger weil die unternehmen
die dann nicht mehr am markt sind eben
nicht von heute auf morgen neu gegründet
werden können das ist ja auch eine der
hauptgründe weshalb wir sagen dass die
kurzarbeiter regel ist vernünftig weil
sie belässt sozusagen auch die
organisatorischen konstrukte die
unternehmen ja darstellen möglichst
lange am markt und deshalb länger es
dauert und je länger wir zuwarten mit
dem vorschlag den ich eingangs gemacht
habe das unternehmen wissen sie bleiben
nicht individuell auf diesen kosten
sitzen desto eher wie ein unternehmen
durchhalten denn wir das nicht machen
scheiden sie aus und dann wird die
erholungsphase umso langsamer verlängert
frau schnetzer gibt's was positives
womit sie um mit werden dieser sendung
enden können wenn wir sagen ja je
nachdem wir ja nicht wissen wie lange es
dauert wo sie sagen wir werden das schon
ganz gut wieder hinkriegen danach ja
wenn man allein an die schuldenquote
denkt wir waren jetzt bei 60% wir werden
vielleicht jetzt durch die maßnahmen auf
80 prozent kommen
das ist ein punkt bei dem waren wir vor
zehn jahren wir haben es durch sehr gute
konjunkturelle phase in den letzten zehn
jahren geschafft abzubauen
insofern bin ich zuversichtlich dass wir
das auch in zukunft schaffen werden
allerdings denke ich nach wie vor
es muss an der stelle darauf geachtet
werden dass wir diesen schuldenberg
nicht zu sehr auf die nächste generation
verschieben sondern dass jetzt alle sich
beteiligen
da muss man beispielsweise auch bei dem
thema rente darüber nachdenken aber
nicht noch weiter könnte und was nicht
aber ich bin zweckoptimist dass wir über
den strukturellen wandel tatsächlich
einen einem putsch bekommen in eine
klimafreundliche wirtschaft wird uns
voran gehen alle was positives
ergiebiger sind am ende dieser sendung
nicht am ende dieser diskussion nicht
werden
hoffe ich es kann aber auch umgekehrt
kommt künftiger wird nun morgen gibt es
ja das treffen der ministerpräsidenten
und der kanzlerin dann wird wieder
beraten über mögliche weitere
lockerungen oder eben auch nicht wir
werden über dieses ergebnis natürlich
morgen in der phoenix runde sprechen mit
dabei ein ehemaliger ministerpräsident
nämlich edmund stoiber und ich hoffe sie
sind dann auch da bis dahin tschüss
[Musik]